Ron McDaniel RNC chairwoman plans to
step down Donald Trump is Trump is
likely to back an election denier
Michael Watley the head of North
Carolina GOP to replace her so
apparently uh Trump got on the phone
with her and then people were expecting
something to happen and then like one of
her I think her Chief of Staff or some
you know one of her top staff members
resigned and now the New York Times
reporting she is uh uh planning to
resign I think there's actually look
there's been a Revolt in the Republican
party over her failure
AB abject failure and uh this is great
this is absolutely fantastic news this
is we are we are excising the Old Guard
establishment neocon types and unip
party garbage from the RNC did you guys
know that I I believe cor someone
searched for this I heard that the
Democrats have raised three times what
the RNC has raised yeah I don't know
what I don't know if it's three times
but I've heard that it's a significantly
larger amount of money because no one's
going to give them money so long as Ron
McDaniel is is is in his position I hope
you're right and thank I'm very very
happy to hear that Rona McDaniel is out
you cannot fail as as regularly as she
did and expect to keep your job and I
mean it's just it's ridiculous that she
that she stuck around the fact like the
fact that she made it after Trump uh you
know lost and 2020 like she should have
been gone then yeah because in my
opinion the whole the reason that that
the reason that Trump lost was because
of the RNC not being prepared with
actual on the ground stuff to compete
with the Democrats the way they were
clearly you know ballot harvesting and
stuff and I don't care that people are
going to sit there and make excuses for
the Republicans I don't care about the
excuses I don't care why you lost you
lost you get fired for that get out of
here RNC reported its worst fundraising
year since 2013 wow a joke they raised
87 million and they started 2024 with
just over 8 million in cash now hold on
what look up turning point USA can we
can we look up their numbers Let's uh
let me do a quick search yeah how much
how much money has she mismanaged though
and squandered like how much money did
she start out with it was millions of
dollars that she had that she did
nothing with that she completely
squandered how much has the RNC
raised since do we know the
RNC are you looking for Turning Point
how much is turning point raised RNC so
we can we can compare 87 million 87
million that's a lot more that uh that's
in 2023 a lot more than I think TP USA
raises but the interesting thing is when
you look at we when we were at Turning
Point uh uh mfest a lot of people were
saying like this is basically replacing
the RNC I mean I I don't yeah that's a
good point that's the vibe I got while I
was there it just felt like if there's
going to be what you would call a
Republican National Convention that's
what the Turning Point feels like and
Des santis didn't go that was crazy I
don't know that was real I like him as
Governor I mean now that he's not
running anymore he's like he's a badass
again yeah it's crazy but he he's got no
Charisma I'm sorry no but I mean like
now that he's not running for president
all of a sudden he's just like when he
said Deport ilhan Omar I was like oh
what where was this guy exactly where's
he been for reference the DNC seems to
have raised 140 million to the RNC 87
million yeah they they embarrassing that
that's more with Joe Biden says Allied
groups uh so it might be just more than
just DNC wow dude the RNC entered 2024
with eight with only $8 million that's
nuts that's
insane holy raised million in the first
month something like that that's nuts
man how much they rais they entered the
year with 8 million in cash and now
they've got how much 87 this I don't
think this article has their total uh
rate
okay here we go they raised 87.2 million
in 2023 ending the year with 8 million
left in the bank wow wow the DNC raised
119 million with 21 million cash on hand
and then I'm not finding turning points
numbers exactly but uh their revenue of
2022 was 55 million that was their
revenue 55 million 55 million they're
starting to replace this is what I was
wondering they're starting to replace
the RNC yeah why would anyone donate to
the RNC at all it used to be that like
Hey we're going to we're going to
support the Republican party and we're
going to support their candidates and
then when you donate they can donate
that money to one of the candidates nah
best thing they could do is make Charlie
Kirk the head of the RNC or we just I
don't know if you take it at this point
yeah I mean it is good that Rona
McDaniel is out but I got I got to be
honest I don't care for the Republican
establishment and I think it's true many
Trump supporters felt the same way
that's why they started using the lion
instead of the uh what the the elephant
right GOP elephant no I didn't know that
yeah they start using a lion for Trump
cuz like it's a different party yeah I
think it's fairly obvious in 2016 and
it's it's it's the Ron Paul generation
the the Ron Paul populace types went Mis
caucus libertarian or they or they went
not all of them some of them went Trump
some of some of the the misus guys are
actually uh speak positively of Trump's
foreign policy despite it not being
perfect but then you get the Bernie
Sanders progressives and there was an
attempted uh ousting of the of the
leadership in the Democrat and
Republican parties in
2016 Donald Trump succeeded Bernie
Sanders failed you want to know you want
to know why happened Place Bernie
Sanders next to Donald Trump there's
your answer no question that was the
best the progressive left could muster
up for a populist Revolt in the
Democratic party yeah Bernie's going to
stand outside the door knocking excuse
me can I please come in and Donald Trump
just hires a bunch of guys battering
rams and he walks it's my tower now
we're taking it and that's what he did
and uh they desperately need they
desperately for their cause need to stop
him but uh they can't here we go with
the outing of Ronald McDaniel finally
holy crap did you say they mentioned a
guy they want to put in as the head of
the RNC already they've already got
a yeah Michael Watley they say he's an
election denier I didn't realize he was
a Democrat who thought Trump was a
Russian agent oh oh oh they're saying he
has questions about potential voter
fraud yeah I mean you know I I I get it
uh election wait what doj arrests New
Jersey Democrat for mail and ballot
fraud uhoh if I if I agree with the doj
am in election now I don't want to be an
election denier guys man I can't believe
it took this long to get rid of Ronald
McDaniel it's almost too little too late
to be honest well well I mean I would
disagree just because of the fact that
it's still you know it's February
there's there's still a lot of time a
lot of time most most elections you
don't have such a clear idea of who the
nominee is going to be this early
usually it's not until at least April
you know you know until you you know
people really kind of shake out so she
might whoever comes in might be able to
do some some good hopefully I I kind of
think it's fair to assume this year will
be the weirdest thing you've ever seen I
know we joke about Ben Shapiro rapping
like aha it's 2024 and Ben Shapiro is
the biggest rapper in the world blah
blah blah and like it's a joke no it's
not really that big a deal like there's
a lot of cultural things that have
happened you know the fjb song hitting
number one we obviously have some
cultural influence on our side I'm
talking about we we have a lot of expect
ations of what's going to happen but I'm
saying like dude if aliens came down and
just abducted Nikki Haley in the middle
of like a speech I would just not be
surprised at all I'm half kidding you
know like maybe not aliens but I'm just
saying right now we expect Trump to be
the nominee I honestly have no idea I I
I I I put my Bet On It place my chips on
that Donald Trump's gonna be the
nominee but I don't know man I mean V I
think made a good point about they will
stop at nothing yeah we literally have
no idea and and I'm I'm here's what I'm
worried about a Black Swan event
happening in the next few months there's
no way to predict it these things happen
you have no idea yeah my worst fear well
no actually this is just one of my fears
is a power out is like a grid down water
down situation for Two Plus
weeks uh something that would cause
water down if the water grid goes out
then disease gets really can get really
nasty they're reporting that the houthis
make cut undersea cables disrupting
International Communications wow when I
I was doing this war gaming in my head
like what's the worst and I'm thinking
okay they they really want to create
like a world order but they want order
they don't want World chaos they want
order so they're not going to knock out
power grids and things like I don't
think that that's the aim is to destroy
and corrupt I think the idea is to
peacefully take control so I don't know
I don't know dep on if if you believe
that they that there is actually a plan
to uh decrease
population why not well they I know
there's a plan that they want to slow
the growth of the population I mean I
think that there's a plan they want to
slow the growth I don't know if they
actually want to go decrease the total
or if they just want to slow the growth
of the total I'm not sure exactly I I I
I think we've got probably a normaly
bias yeah but not an optimism bias I
think many of us actually are concerned
about what's going to happen this year
but you know I've been thinking about
this every day I wake up I got routine
you know what I mean we come in I sit
down I got my little spin drift right
here here and we got our Bill Tong and
we do the show every day and I wake up
in the morning and I read the news every
day and part of me is thinking like I
kind of feel like it is reasonable to
expect that at some point this year
something will happen that will
completely disrupt our ability to have
some kind of routine we saw that with Co
that shattered
everything it is 2024 it is four years
on they do not want Trump to win by any
means necessary so I kind of just feel
like Black Swan event I don't know what
it's going to be
yeah I don't know man I don't know
either I I there's a significant part of
me that doesn't believe that Donald
Trump will be you know the president in
2025 no matter what happens of the Neo
Confederacy he will be right of the UN
that's another question I mean I that's
I don't I don't I don't I don't want to
talk about that but like I I just don't
think that that I don't think that the
the the establishment will allow it I I
think that they're going to come up with
some kind of EXC use whether it be
whether it be something that actually
happens in on Election Day or not you
know we we already saw that they said he
has no immunity yeah yeah so I'm I'm I'm
game man uh let's arrest Barack Obama
stat that's something you know there was
I think it was darl Isa I retweeted
something today just a little while ago
I think it was darl Isa that was making
Illusions to that uh exact thing that if
it is that if the case is that Donald
Trump does not have immunity then Barack
Obama doesn't either and of course and
so so all we need is some uh Republican
in uh uh I don't law enforcement
anywhere with some balls to initiate the
criminal proceedings against Barack
Obama for the extrajudicial
assassination of anoir alaki and his son
abduraman alaki yep but you know um
Republicans are cowards oh man that's
not fair dude weak cowards that's not
that's still not fair it is not fair to
call Republic because you're insulting
weak cowards uh uans are worse than that
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net